عندما نفكر في الدول الفاشلة ، فإن
الصور التي تتبادر إلى الذهن هي أفغانستان
أو اليمن أو جنوب السودان ،
لكن لبنان ذات يوم ، البلد الأكثر سحرًا
في الشرق الأوسط ،
ينضم إلى تلك الرتب
يوم الإثنين ، أعلن رئيس
الوزراء اللبناني الأسبق سعد الحريري
أنه سيعلق 17-  سنة من
العمل السياسي ولن يسعى إلى إعادة انتخابه
لنفسه أو لحزبه
لرجل كانت عائلته في
قلب التاريخ السياسي للبنان ما بعد الحرب.
قراره
لكن انسحاب الحريري من المجال السياسي
لن يكون ممكناً لولا
الانهيار الكامل للاقتصاد
اللبناني في بيان صادم صدر يوم الثلاثاء
، وصف البنك الدولي هذا بأنه أحد
أعنف الانهيارات الاقتصادية التي
شهدها العالم منذ عام 1850.
إليكم صورة  من الانهيار في
البيانات
في عام 2020 ، انخفض الناتج المحلي الإجمالي بنسبة مذهلة بلغت 21 ،
بينما انتعشت بلدان أخرى
من الارتفاع الأولي.  انخفض
إجمالي الناتج المحلي في لبنان
العام الماضي بنسبة تقديرية 10.5 في المائة ،
ما يبدو أنه
بلغ 52 مليار دولار في عام 2019 بالدولار.
البلدان التي فحصها
البنك الدولي ،
يتضح حجم الأزمة بالنسبة للبنانيين العاديين في كل مكان
تنظر إليه ، حيث انخفضت قيمة العملة
بأكثر من 90 منذ أن
بلغ متوسط التضخم في عام 2019 145 في
لعام الماضي ، تضاعفت أسعار ال
قل الغذائي والملابس أر
ع مرات أكثر.  يعيش الآن أكثر من 70 في المائة من
السكان في فقر
حيث ارتفعت أسعار الوقود والأدوية.
يعني انهيار العملة أن رواتبهم لا
تساوي كثيرًا على أي حال.
تشير رويترز إلى أن راتب الجندي
كان يساوي تسعمائة دولار
شهريًا  إنها تساوي الآن خمسين دولارًا ،
لماذا يحدث هذا الأمر الذي يضعه البنك الدولي
بصراحة غير معهود في تسميته
بالاكتئاب المتعمد الذي
نظمته النخبة في البلاد ، وهي
النخبة السياسية التي قامت
منذ نهاية الحرب الأهلية في
أوائل التسعينيات من القرن الماضي
باستفزاز الدولة لأي شيء.  الأموال التي
يمكن أن تنتزعها دون أي قلق
واضح على بقاء الشعب اللبناني ،
كانت الحرب ضد المسيحيين ضد
طائفة المسلمين ضد الطائفة ، وكان حلها هو
اتفاق تقاسم السلطة الذي
تم تقسيم الحكومة بين مسيحيين شيعة ومسلمين سنة
وأرمن
كما الصحفية رانيا  كتب أبو زاعي مؤخرًا في مجلة New York Times
أن
أمراء الحرب الطائفيين أصبحوا
سياسيين طائفيين وشكلوا
الحكومة للتهرب من المساءلة عن
الاستغلال الوقح للقضاء وأن
الضوابط الأخرى على الحكومة كانت
فسادًا معاقًا عمدًا
وأصبحت شبكات المحسوبية
سمات مركزية
للدولة وقد امتدت إلى  في حالة غير
عادية  جزء نشط من الاقتصاد اللبناني ،
وفقًا لبحث أجرته
الجامعة الأمريكية في بيروت عام 2014 ، تمتلك 29 من
أصول القطاع المصرفي فقط
ثماني عائلات مرتبطة سياسيًا
، وقد أثارت الأزمة الحالية غضب
الجمهور وأدت إلى احتجاجات واسعة النطاق
ولكن لم يحدث أي منها.  أدى إلى أي تغيير حقيقي
نحكم عليه ضد الفساد في كل مكان ،
لكن مثال لبنان يوضح كيف أنه عندما
ينتشر كل
ما يمكن أن يدمر
بلدًا تقريبًا